>> WE GOOFED.
THAT WAS THE ADMISSION
ESSENTIALLY FROM THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL DIRECTOR
ROCHELLE WALENSKY WHEN SHE
CALLED FOR AN OVERHAUL TO THE
AGENT SAYING IN RESPONSE TO
COVID-19, THE C.D.C. DID NOT
MEET MANY EXPECTATIONS OF THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
SHE DIDN'T GET INTO SPECIFICS
ABOUT WHAT THEY BOTCHED AND
WHEN.
COULD HAVE SOMETHING TO DO WITH
DON'T WEAR MASKS, DO WEAR
MASKS, GET ONE SHOT, 50 SHOTS,
WHATEVER THE CONFUSION, THEY'RE
TRYING TO CLARIFY IT NOW WITH A
COMPLETE REVAMP OF THE AGENCY.
WHO IS AFFECTED AND WHAT'S
AFFECTED WITH DR. ROBERT
REDFIELD WITH THE FORMER C.D.C.
DIRECTOR UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
KIND ENOUGH TO JOIN US.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU, NEIL.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> WHAT IS SHE SAYING, DOCTOR.
IS SHE RIGHT?
DID THE C.D.C. BOTCH IT?
>> WELL, NEIL, I THINK AT THE
HEART OF THIS IS WHEN THEY
REALLY TALK ABOUT A RESET IS
WHAT THE PRIMARY ROLE OF THE
C.D.C. IS.
IS IT AN ACADEMIC INSTITUTION?
OR IS IT A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE AGENCY?
WHEN IT STARTED 75 YEARS AGO
WORKING WITH THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT TO WORK ON MALARIA,
IT WAS A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND WHAT IT'S MORPHED INTO OVER
75 YEARS IS TO HAVE MORE OF A
CULTURE OF AN ACADEMIC
INSTITUTION.
I THINK AT THE HEART OF THIS
REPORT AND WHAT THE DIRECTOR
HAS COMMENTED ON IS IT'S REALLY
TIME FOR C.D.C. TO LOOK IN THE
MIRROR, KIND OF SEE WHAT IT'S
BECOME, AND ASK THE QUESTION,
ITS CULTURE AND STRUCTURE
OPTIMIZED AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE AGENCY?
OR IS IT OPTIMIZED AS AN
ACADEMIC INSTITUTION?
AND I THINK THAT'S THE HEART OF
IT.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG JOURNEY
TO TRY TO CHANGE THE CULTURE OF
THE AGENCY AND REALLY MAKE IT
SO IT CAN BE A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE.
NEIL: YOU MIGHT BE RIGHT ON
THAT.
YOU'RE SO BRILLIANT, DOCTOR,
YOU LOST ME WITH THAT.
I WANT TO UNDERSTAND AND GET TO
THE BRASS TACKS ON THIS.
WAS IT THE GUIDANCE WAS WRONG?
AND THEN WE CAN GET INTO THE
SPECIFICS OF THAT.
WEARING MASKS, SAID ORIGINALLY
A BAD IDEA, NOT NECESSARY AND
THEN EVERYBODY WEAR MASKS.
IS IT ON LOCKDOWN?
AND KEEPING PEOPLE HOME?
THAT THAT WAS ADVISABLE IN THE
BEGINNING, WAS THAT A MISTAKE?
AND FOR FUTURE PANDEMICS, IS
THE SIGNAL THAT THOSE KIND OF
THINGS WILL NOT HAPPEN IN THE
FUTURE?
>> WELL, CLEARLY, THE MANDATES
AND THE LOCKDOWNS AND THE
CLOSING OF THE SCHOOLS TO
VIRTUAL LEARNING, ALL OF THAT
WAS A PUBLIC HEALTH MISTAKE,
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
NEIL: WHAT IF EVERYBODY HAD
GONE ABOUT THEIR NORMAL ROLES
AND BACK TO WORK AND CROWDED
SITUATIONS YOU DON'T THINK AT
SOME LEVEL THAT WOULD HAVE MADE
THINGS EVEN WORSE OR RETROSPECT
YOU SAY NO IT WOULDN'T?
REMEMBER, THAT'S PRE-VACCINE.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT CLEARLY,
MY VIEW WAS THAT WE TAKE A
PAUSE, EVALUATE HOW TO DO
THINGS IN A SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE WAY, BUT SHUTTING
DOWN THE SCHOOLS WAS MUCH
GREATER PUBLIC HEALTH HARM TO
THE KIDS THAN KEEPING THE
SCHOOLS OPEN.
NEIL: DOCTOR, I'M SORRY TO KEEP
JUMPING ON YOU RUDELY.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION.
YOU WOULD HAVE NOT DONE THE
SCHOOL SHUTDOWN THING, BUT YOU
WOULD HAVE EMBRACED, AS THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION DID
INITIALLY, WITH SOME
RELUCTANCE, THIS IDEA OF
EVERYONE DIALING THINGS BACK,
MAYBE, YOU KNOW, DOING THEIR
JOBS FROM THEIR HOMES, JUST NOT
EXTENDING THAT TO KEEPING OUR
KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL?
>> YEAH, I WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY
SELECT ON TRYING TO LOOK AT
EACH ACTIVITY HOW THEY DO IT
SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE RESTAURANT
BUSINESS, I WOULD HAVE, YOU
KNOW, STOPPED LOUD MUSIC AND
PEOPLE STANDING AROUND BARS,
BUT I WOULD HAVE HAD PEOPLE
STILL BE ABLE TO GO INTO
RESTAURANTS.
I THINK THERE WAS A MISTAKE IN
THOSE REGARDS, BUT I THINK AT
THE HEART OF IT, NEIL, WHAT I
WAS TRYING TO GET AT, C.D.C.
HAS A TENDENCY TO COME UP WITH
INFORMATION ONCE THEY HAVE ALL
THE DATA, IT'S ALREADY WRAPPED
UP IN A BOW, IT'S PERFECT, IT'S
READY FOR PUBLICATION IN THE
SCIENTIFIC JOURNAL.
AND WHAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE AGENCIES HAVE TO DO IS
TAKE INFORMATION IN REAL-TIME
AND TRY TO MAKE REAL-TIME
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN MODIFY
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AS DATA
EVOLVES, BUT I ALWAYS GIVE THE
EXAMPLE OF MY FIRST BRIEFING
THAT I HAD AS C.D.C. ON OPIOID
DEATHS.
IT WAS A WEEK OR SO AFTER I WAS
DIRECTOR AND WHEN I FINISHED
THE BRIEFING I ASKED THE C.D.C.
EXPERTS WHAT THE DATA WAS
THROUGH AND THEY TOLD ME IT WAS
THROUGH MARCH OF 2015 AND I
SAID IT'S APRIL 2018.
AND THEY WERE EXPLAINING TO ME
THE COMPLEXITIES OF GETTING
DATA AND I WAS EXPLAINING TO
THEM THAT DOESN'T HELP TO
LAUNCH A PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE
BASED ON DATA THREE YEARS OLD.
I THINK THAT'S THE HEART OF IT.
NEIL: AND THAT DOES MAKE SENSE.
I DO WONDER, NO MATTER WHAT THE
CHANGES ARE, DOCTOR, GOING
FORWARD, IS IT YOUR BELIEF THAT
VACCINES WERE GOOD, THAT
GETTING SO MANY AMERICANS, I
BELIEVE UP TO EIGHT OUT OF 10
VACCINATED WAS GOOD?
>> I THINK IT'S CRITICAL.
NEIL.
I THINK WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE.
VACCINES ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
GIFT TO SCIENCE TO MODERN
MEDICINE.
THEY DO WORK.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE COVID
VACCINE IS PEOPLE NEED TO THINK
OF IT MORE LIKE A MEDICINE THAN
A VACCINE.
IN OTHER WORDS, A VACCINE YOU
TAKE ONCE AND YOU'RE DONE.
THE COVID VACCINE ONLY WORKS
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME.
IT ORIGINALLY WUHAN STRAIN
ABOUT 8 TO 12 MONTHS, DELTA 4
TO 5.
OMICRON FOUR MONTHS AND NOW THE
OMICRON 4-5 PROBABLY THREE
MONTHS AND SHOULDN'T SURPRISE
US.
IF I GET INFECTED WITH OMICRON
5, THE IMMUNITY WILL ONLY
PROTECT ME FOR ABOUT THREE TO
FOUR MONTHS.
NEIL: WELL SAID.
DOCTOR, VERY GOOD SEEING YOU.